whether it's jace fox if it's any  character or comic book character really  is what are the differentiators what are  the motivators jace is i will fight so  that people understand right from wrong  being part of the system representing  and an individual can make a difference  so now we're taking jace and we're  moving into a real space we're setting a  new and very specific tone for jace in  new york have conversations about  policing not just socio-political  conversations but okay a mask shows up  in new york what do we do it's batman  it's the dc universe but it's a little  bit more real expect his own roads  expect his own partners expect his own  dilemmas who is his joker going to be  you will now see the family embrace the  speculation of future state the promise  of fierce state the backstory of second  son  almost every month expect a surprise  you